So, welcome everybody.
To the 12th and
last lecture from my side for the
discourse on robot learning.
Um
before I start with today's topic on the
frontier and open problems.
I did made a slide but
>> [clears throat]
>> just a quick announcement for the
project.
We will send you an email tonight with
some information
for the PCs where you will be able to
test your policies. Um so,
we basically we found a bunch of PCs at
my work in Microsoft and we brought them
to ETH. We put them in a room
and this will be the PCs that you will
also deploy your policies on in demo
day.
And so, we will give you information on
how you can access them I think starting
tomorrow
like later tonight via email. Um so,
>> [clears throat]
>> yeah, that was a kind of a quick
announcement before we dive
deep into today's topic. Um
which is I'm going to talk today a
little bit about
like frontier and and open problems in
in robot learning. And then I will end a
little bit with
some tips also that I found helpful on
how to research for example like if
you're interested in tackling any of
these problems.
Um
>> [clears throat]
>> so, to begin with let's start with
something you've probably seen if you
follow robotics on social media. Um
because
pretty much every single week
someone declares that robotics is is
solved
or or manipulation is solved.
Um and yeah, so I don't know a few days
ago like you know, Genesis AI dropped a
a new announcement and they declared
this is the we are approaching the end
game for robotics. Um
Uh Brett Adcock also tweeted um
about having their chat GPT moment for
robotics in their lab.
uh 2 years ago. Um we're still waiting
on that.
Um
>> [clears throat]
>> Uh and others uh promise like the the
road map to physical HRI and so forth.
And so um I'm not saying um
this is not like criticizing or I'm not
saying you shouldn't believe this
announcement or anything, but like just
like take them uh you might want to take
them with a grain of salt
um because uh essentially uh you know,
how can you believe them is somebody
else already uh declared to have solved
robotics uh the week before, right?
So
uh
what happens when you ask to uh a robot
to actually generalize, right? Um and so
on the left you can see uh like a Boston
Dynamics humanoid
and on the right a mobile manipulator
from Stanford trying to perform
uh cooking-related tasks in a kitchen
uh environment. And uh as you can see uh
for
the the kitchen one uh you might
uh
uh will have to wait quite a long time
until the robot can cook dinner for you.
Um now these two videos are not
absolutely the latest results. Um
they're a few years old. Um but they're
kind of representative of something
important, which is um
when [clears throat] you take the robot
out of the lab and you know, out of the
lab setting and put it in a new um you
know, environment and ask it to
generalize then
uh like maybe with the new lighting, new
objects, new camera viewpoints and so
forth, like things things start to break
uh very quickly. Um and so um
although looking at like the very
impressive and very cool like um demo
videos on on social media,
um you know, you might be inclined to to
to believe that robotics is solved. Um
if you take the same robot on the same
demo and put like put it in the next
room
uh
outside like its training distribution,
it will probably like fail quite quite
badly.
Um
so how do these uh cool uh like Twitter
demos that supposedly uh are the chat
GPT moment for robotics um or the end
game uh work or how do they get made? Um
so, I want to share with you the uh
really not-so-secret recipe um
on how you can do a a rockstar demo uh
on real robots. Um so, first of all like
just collect uh training data um on your
own. Don't rely on anybody else to do
so. Just collect as much training data
as possible on your target uh platform.
Um the second step is um
>> [clears throat]
>> train a behavior cloning policy
uh and just keep collecting data until
extrapolation becomes interpolation for
your policy.
Um and then the third, uh if possible,
try to train and test on the same day uh
to avoid any distributional shifts
whatsoever in the environment, no
changes in the lighting, I know what
changes in on camera viewpoints, table
heights, and nothing.
Right? Um and so, it turns out um you
can get a lot of money from VCs for
following this very simple recipe.
Um
So, but what is the actual problem we're
trying to solve in robotics? And I like
to think um
about generalization as this kind of
like um hierarchy of scopes where um
like the most impressive demos you see
are operating in this very narrow um
kind of like between one object and one
room uh kind of kind of um circle. Um
and of course like you know, like
there's more ambitious work trying to
pull towards like you know, maybe like
generalizing the one building
uh kind of environment.
Um but the real goal is like the world,
right? Um and because uh
humans generalize to the real world and
um you don't need to have seen um, like
every kitchen to cook in,
uh, in order, uh, to cook in a new
kitchen, right? Uh, you don't need to
have picked up every possible, like,
object or every possible mark in the
world, uh, to understand how you need to
grasp, like, uh, a new unseen mark,
right? Um, and so, basically, like, you
know, you you kind of stitch together
your knowledge, um,
reason about novel situations, and
compose what you already know in novel
ways to to be able to, um, do this sort
of generalization,
um,
and, uh, that's not interpolation,
right? Like, it's really like kind of
this
um, this missing, um, like, intelligent
reasoning or whatever you want to call
it, uh,
thing that, um,
is still very elusive for our robot
policies. Like, we are not there yet.
>> [snorts]
>> Um, and so, this really goes a little
bit beyond just collecting more data in
order to, um, achieve these abilities,
right?
Um, and so, where we are today is that
we have kind of, like, powerful
generalist models, often in the form of,
like, VLMs, for example, that
are trained on internet-scale data and
generalize broadly, um, but often lack
this physical grounding, um, so, they
can kind of describe, for example, an
image with a glass on a table, but, um,
they don't truly understand what will
happen if, um,
>> [clears throat]
>> if they push, uh, the, um, this off the,
um, off the edge and that it breaks
apart, right?
Um,
and, um, this kind of also applies to
generative video models, uh, where, I
don't know, like, models like Sora can,
um, synthesize really, um,
very uh, realistic-looking, like, kind
of physical interactions, right? Like,
liquids pouring or or objects falling,
um, but if you look closely, they they
they do actually tend to violate, like,
physical,
uh, basic physics, um, so, they are very
good at making it look like they um like
like the world, but don't really like
fully understand um
>> [clears throat]
>> like physics, for example.
And so, um on the other hand, like we we
we do have like specialists um kind of
embodied models or policies um that can
perform like uh heterogeneous um sorry,
uh dexterous tasks
uh and consume like more heterogeneous
uh sensing modalities in order to better
interact in the in the world. Um, but uh
do tend to uh not generalize um kind of
to broader uh in the wild tasks. And so,
the our our question in robot learning
is kind of like to um you know, to kind
of find like the the the best of the
both worlds, right?
Um And so, what is the path forward? Um
I believe that um
in order to achieve like this this sort
of like um true embodied uh
intelligence,
uh we we we need to move kind of to
beyond like this this passive data um um
uh um that like uh foundation models are
trained on towards grounding them in the
in the physical world um by by feeding
them
uh like richer embodied data um that is
inherently multimodal, spatial
uh and also temporal. Um and so, uh
ideally, this would then help us um
build agents that can not like describe
the world, but actually um
>> [clears throat]
>> reason and and like more intelligently
interact uh with with it.
So, this brings us to the kind of first
open problem. Uh what is the best uh
backbone for robotics, right? And it
seems we have um this kind of three uh
camps in the community right now.
And the first one says like, "Oh, let's
use a vision uh language model because
VLMs already come
uh with um all this like rich semantic
knowledge uh about the world um and they
can reason about scenes and so forth. Um
so, we can fine-tune them on some robot
data,
uh and then you get like this, let's
say, object-level um semantic
generalization for free.
Um the second camp says, uh let's use a
generative video model um
because they better understand temporal
dynamics. Um
They kind of better model um how the
environment or the world uh evolves
around uh across time.
Um
>> [clears throat]
>> and um
their pre-training is a little bit more
similar um to what a robot policy um
needs to do, like essentially like
reasoning over consequences of of the
actions, right?
Um and then there is the maybe third
camp that maybe is a little bit more
provocative that says like, "Well,
um the backbone actually doesn't matter
that much if we have enough uh
real-world uh robot data, then we can
just train everything from scratch.
Uh and forget about internet
pre-training. Like, we just care about
robotics. Let's just like collect robot
data, train a big model on it. That's
it."
Um and uh well, it's interestingly um
Scott Reed gave a um kind of like a
guest lecture on exactly this topic um
a few weeks ago. Uh so, if you missed
it, uh it's on YouTube. Um you can find
it on the course
uh website.
And uh invite you to to watch it um if
you're interested in this.
Um And so, yeah, I think in general like
each of these positions has like serious
proponents. Um but the jury is kind of
still out on on which one is the the
best way to move forward.
Um and this is closely related the the
backbone uh question is very closely
related also to the data question,
right? What is the best data recipe for
for robotics
uh or for training a like kind of like
more generalist robot policy?
Right, so
um there are like different approaches
like for example on the left this could
be like this three three tier um
approach where
you start with web data
um
to have like kind of good uh world
knowledge and and grounding language
grounding.
And then you um
uh scale uh with some like simulated uh
interaction
uh for kind of like scalable cheap like
experience
uh and then like kind of a a little real
world robot data on top uh to kind of
bridge the sim-to-real gap.
Um the second uh proponent uh could be
like stripping down the the simulation
uh layer
um
>> [clears throat]
>> because um well the argument
um these companies is that well um
you know like simulating um the entire
world accurately is um very very
challenging and needs a lot of
engineering and you might rather um
better invest the time uh actually
collecting real world data instead of
trying to figure how to um simulate um
all all the physics and everything.
Right?
Um
and here are a few of more data recipes
that follow some of the uh background
choices um we just discussed. So on the
left this would be like [clears throat]
a kind of
uh like a data recipe that treats uh
video as a first class citizen uh where
you kind of start training maybe on
general like YouTube like internet
videos
um then add some human egocentric uh
videos for mid training
uh and then end post training it um
uh to predict robot actions.
Um and um the intuition as a
forementioned is that
uh video is a far richer prior for
embodied tasks than
uh let's say visual question answering
tasks uh could ever be.
Um and then on the on the right um you
can see like kind of the like the from
scratch recipe of
just training like all the layers like
with real world data maybe like it
varies a bit maybe with on the type of
annotations and granularity but just
like really going all in on the real
world
data.
Um,
>> [clears throat]
>> So, once you've decided on your data
recipe, um, you also face kind of the
next question of like how do you
actually collect like real world data,
right? Um, at scale cuz all of the like
no matter what like in the end like you
will need some like more or less like
real world data.
Um, and so what you're looking at here
is kind of like a zoo of, um,
data collection interfaces um, each
making different trade-offs uh, between
scalability
um, alignment with the target embodiment
uh, and um, the complexity of the tasks
um, that you can demonstrate. Um,
so for example, um, Yumi style grippers
um, as you saw in the talk, um, from uh,
Cheng
um, are more scalable than teleoperation
robots um, but now you need to do like
some sort of cross embodiment learning.
Um, puppeteering gives you higher
quality data than um, VR teleop for
example, but it's the most expensive one
uh, to collect as you need also like a
leader follower
uh, arm setups um, and this means you
will now also have more hardware to
break.
>> [snorts]
>> Um,
>> [clears throat]
>> and on this plot you can see a little
bit the trade-offs between the um, data
scalability and the hardware alignment.
Um, so on the uh, vertical on the Y axis
you can see the how much data you can
collect uh, ranging from thousands to
uh,
tens of millions of of hours and on the
horizontal axis um,
>> [clears throat]
>> um, you can see how close how closely
this data aligns with um, the actual
hardware that you want to deploy
on.
And so, egocentric videos
gives you tens of millions of hours of
data, but it's human data, it's not
robot data.
So, there is some quite a big embodiment
gap.
Um
While teleop gives you perfectly aligned
data
with the robot
fully in the loop,
but you are kind of a bit more capped in
terms of like the data volume because
it's like slower and expensive. And
data wearables like let's say for
example gloves sit somewhere in the
middle.
Um so, yeah, basically solving these
trade-offs
or finding like your ways around it like
for example, I don't know like by having
a humanoid robot to better like leverage
like egocentric videos or things like
that
is one of one of the open problems that
community is
looking at.
So,
what is a um
what is kind of like the goal we are
working towards?
Um
And in general, I think maybe one good
framing framing is that ideally we would
like to have like dextrous generalist
policies.
>> [clears throat]
>> And the challenge is that
um so far
dexterity and generalization have
required somewhat different ingredients
for success.
Um so, this means if you think about it
like for example for dexterity
you typically need high frequency
control. Um but this is like a little
bit at odds with running very large
foundation models, right? Cuz they're
like more slow and computationally more
expensive. Um for dextrous Um, dexterity
you also typically need more
heterogeneous sensing, for example, like
touch sensing
um, modalities that most foundation
models, um,
simply don't consume today.
Um, and on the other hand, if you want
if you care about pushing
generalization, um,
then, um, you need to leverage, uh,
foundation models, right? Uh,
and, uh, also for robotics, you also
need to think about mobility because,
um,
uh, robots that can, uh, move across
different, uh, environments, uh,
and accumulate, uh, experience, um,
across different, like, rooms and and
buildings and so on, uh, they, uh, can
learn to generalize better than, uh, the
same robots if they are just like bolted
onto a table and like not moving a lot
and just like kind of seeing the same
scene, right?
Um,
so, the goal, um,
uh, is, um, kind of like we want to be
like at the intersection of this Venn
diagram, um, where we want to have,
like, systems that, um, are dexterous,
um, but, um,
>> [clears throat]
>> and can handle, like, kind of the
complexities of all the, uh,
uh, real manipulation tasks, um, but
that are, um, general general enough,
um, to do so across, um,
like, um, unstructured environments and
like any kind of, like, unseen objects
that we throw at them.
And so, um, yeah, most systems are kind
of like in one of two camps, but like
that's one of the open problems, um, to
try to develop, um, algorithms and
systems that kind of, uh, go more
towards this goal of, um, having like,
uh, dexterous generalist policies that
generalize.
Um,
>> [clears throat]
>> so, let me maybe illustrate a point
about dexterity requiring more than
vision, uh, with kind of like a personal
video, um,
from, uh, a PhD
Oh, I think you don't
Can you hear the sound?
Sorry, I didn't check.
Okay, so you you can't hear the sound,
but
um
what what is happening here is so
uh I spent quite a lot of time training
like a model that would take like an RGB
image as an input and predict 3D shapes
and
objects pose. Um
>> [clears throat]
>> um so that even though um
like a robot the robot had like a depth
camera
cuz they were like partially occluded,
um you could um kind of predict like the
object like like for example the handle
of the mug and so on like very
accurately to better grasp it. Um and
what you what you see here is that the
robot like misses the handle, um just
goes for grasping the mug directly, and
absolutely destroys it
because it has no touch or or force
feedback. So, it was kind of like doing
a blind
grasp that was like too powerful.
Um and I think that our current VLAs are
also probably still
annihilating objects because we haven't
made that much progress in this front.
Um and
I think our robots are still
kind of blind most of the time when
we're making contact with objects.
And so, your first idea could be well,
we
uh if you remember we covered like
natively in multimodal models
earlier in the course, um
the idea being that instead of bolting
like additional modalities to like
vision, we could like train a unified
transformer that can
from scratch across all modalities
jointly, right?
Um
>> [clears throat]
>> so, we could throw in
like touch, force, proprioception, all
of this into it, and we solve the
problem, right?
Um
but the issue is that um the moment
[clears throat] you try to do that, um
you uh basically run into like the what
I would call the long tail of robot
sensing.
And um there are like a few issues with
this, and um the first and foremost, as
you probably can guess, is the data
scarcity. So, many of the modalities
that matter for dexterity, uh like
touch, tactile uh feedback, force,
um are usually not available at scale,
um
uh cuz the hardware
is is expensive, it's fragile, um and
also like not very standardized, so it's
still kind of very researchy.
Um and the second pairing,
so even when um individual modalities
exist, um for example, cross-modal
paired data, where you have like all the
modalities you wish kind of paired at
the same time, um that is nearly
nonexistent.
Um
and third, the heterogeneity. Um so,
sensors um vary a lot across different
robot embodiments, which
uh makes also transfer uh quite hard.
Um so, and given the scarcity of this
paired multimodal data, um there's also
like an interesting question, um for
example, um can we use language as a
bridge um to reason across modalities um
that we haven't seen uh
before together?
Uh because we have like kind of um
uh disjoint amounts of data, right?
Like, for example, we might have large
amounts of vision language data, some
[clears throat] audio data, uh and maybe
like small um data of touch, um
um so, but but no data to train all of
this like simultaneously, right? At
scale.
So,
um here's some initial work we did at
Berkeley um on how you can give uh VLAs
uh senses they were never trained on,
like touch or audio, um by using
language as a semantic uh uh of glue uh
to bridge all um sorry, not to bridge,
to bind all these um heterogeneous
modalities.
Um
>> [clears throat]
>> So,
I won't go into the details, but
basically um this unlocks um like VLA's
new cross-modal reasoning abilities um
such as, for example, asking um
to grasp the object that feels uh like a
pineapple, but is brown, for example. Um
and so,
here here you can see like a a few
different things that then this enables
you to do, like multimodal prompting, um
cross-modal uh like audio-visual
prompting, um or even um
uh
>> [clears throat]
>> generation of object uh
object descriptions uh up on
interaction. So, for example, um
uh on the in this case here, uh this is
like kind of the scenario where the
robot like grasps into a shopping bag,
and it can't see anything with the
camera, and it grasps like some random
object, and with um based on like the
touch uh sensor, then like describes
what it thinks it's feeling.
Um so, uh yeah. So, similar to what a
human could do, right?
>> [snorts]
>> Um This slide uh connects directly with
what we covered last week on reasoning
with LLMs and VLAs.
Um and I want to like kind of maybe
touch upon briefly um
uh on maybe like a a broader question
for um
uh for you guys on like when and how
should a robot actually reason,
right?
>> [clears throat]
>> So,
because now if you um think about, okay,
like um your future robot butler um that
is like, you know, assisting you at
home, um reasoning will probably be um
on like a spectrum um
depending on like your policies'
confidence, right? So,
uh when the task you're um
uh tasking your robot is in
distribution, right? So, maybe it's like
a known object, a known task it already
has done before. It's like
it has a training data for this.
Um, then we probably don't want to
reason, right? We just like want to run
our policy at the highest frequency as
possible.
Um,
because [clears throat] well, we don't
want to like waste computation.
Um, but then when you detect that your
policy is not completely sure um, about
what to do because maybe it's like a new
object or uh, maybe the lighting is
different or something. Um,
that's where
test time compute adaptive test time
compute becomes valuable, right? Uh, and
basically with like the
some of the techniques we saw last week
we can try to think through
like the task at hand
by spending more tokens on it at test
time uh, to solve it, right?
Um, and then
on the third column, this is like the
very out of distribution
when [clears throat] the task is not or
the situation is not solvable with test
time compute or more thinking or more
reasoning um, then the safest thing is
to stop
and ask a human for help, for example.
Um,
but this raises like like I think this
makes kind of sense.
But it raises
an immediate question.
How does a model actually know what it
doesn't know?
Because that's the whole like the whole
adaptive reasoning framework from like
the slide before. Um,
so [clears throat] scaling up compute
when like the policy is uncertain,
escalating when it's out of distribution
and so on. Um, actually assumes that we
have a reliable way to detect when the
model is uncertain in the first place.
And it turns out that it's a very big
assumption for our current machine
learning models.
And so this is the fundamentally the
problem of
introspection. So knowing when a model
does not know. And
it remains really one of the is really
one of the central problems in machine
learning.
And arguably it becomes even harder as
we scale our models up. Because large
models are often very good at pattern
matching
or sorry pattern completion when um
while [clears throat]
remaining poorly calibrated about their
competence. Because usually because they
have seen like so much data, right? Um
like
generally novel situation can still
appear superficially familiar
making out of distribution detection
very very difficult. And
in robotics it kind of is even harder
because failure can arise along so many
different dimensions, right? It could be
like objects, environments, embodiments,
tasks. Um
sensor noise
and so forth, right?
And so
like a policy can be overconfident or
appear confident while being wrong for
entirely the
different reasons, right?
Um this connects to another limitation
on where the field stands today.
Um as as you have seen in the course
most of the
current
robot learning
models rely on imitation learning.
Um and as we saw earlier in the course
this means that
um policy is bounded by uh the
demonstrations in the data set.
Now, um
think about like this kind of toy
example, right? Uh and uh how like this
what this means in practice. So, um
for this toy example, this means that no
matter how how large your model is, if
your training data consists only of
demonstrations going from state one to
two and from um state uh
two to three,
then um
the policy has no way of learning um
that there might be a better path like
going from uh one to three.
Um
>> [clears throat]
>> or
or that there might be even be like a
different way of
uh solving uh a certain task that is
>> [clears throat]
>> uh
not one that a human operator uh might
demonstrate.
So, how do we break through um through
this imitation?
And [clears throat] um as you have
probably guessed and al- also we have
seen in the lecture before,
uh one of the possible answers could be
reinforcement learning
uh because um as you've seen the
reinforcement learning is um
uh well suited to to learn near optimal
policies from suboptimal data by
stitching together trajectories. Um
so, in in in this example, like for
example with offline RL, it would
actually be able to learn that um like
there exists a better trajectory uh that
was not demonstrated in in the uh data
set.
And um and we have seen how uh RL is
really um fueling a lot of um new
capabilities in other areas such as
reasoning, agents, uh knowledge
discovery, and so forth. Um
but scaling reinforcement learning for
real uh robots has been very very
challenging. Uh and it still requires uh
a lot of uh algorithmic uh innovation.
So, not just more compute. Um
>> [clears throat]
>> so, I think really getting um RL to work
uh at scale for robotics is is probably
one of the highest impact things um that
uh you could work on uh right now.
Now, figuring out RL for robotics might
be also important to achieve, let's say
um one of the holy grails of robot
learning, which is the data flywheel.
Uh like it is one of the kind of main
goals of of like the community. Um I
don't probably you've already heard this
before. Um
the idea is pretty simple.
Um so, we know from the bitter lesson
that more data uh
usually translates to better models.
Uh and so, better learning and models
produce uh like more capable robots and
uh more capable robots get deployed more
widely.
Uh and then, you know, with more
deployments, we could generate even more
training data. And then, like this cycle
like compounds itself, and you get like
kind of like more data, better models,
and so forth.
>> [snorts]
>> Right?
Um
So,
in order to get the flywheel spinning,
um
kind of like the the first idea um that
we could have is, okay, like we can
uh co-train uh our models on both like
the expert data, let's say um like your
teleop data um that we have collected um
and uh and then, uh the autonomous
robots, so like the data that is being
generated um at the deployment.
Right? And then, we can just like we
have more data, we train on this.
Beautiful. Amazing.
Um
>> [clears throat]
>> Uh it turns out this is a more
challenging problem than one might think
from um the outside or from the surface
um because if you look at the at these
two data distributions,
um they look very, very differently. Um
Um,
so while the expert of data is, um,
kind of, uh, optimal, usually higher
frequency, like smooth, um, autonomous
rollouts will, you know, often be like
quite longer in in time. It will take
longer to to do the same task often, um,
because maybe the policy doesn't always,
um, choose the optimal trajectory.
Uh, it can also be jerky, uh, and
suboptimal. And so, if you like naively
mix, um, both of them,
let's say with imitation learning,
um, that will not work really well. Um,
the model will kind of get confused
with,
um, by the mismatch in kind of the
quality, frequency, and the, um,
kind of like just in general like the
data distribution.
Um,
and so this is another area where, uh,
new algorithms are are needed, um,
because we need methods that can, um,
learn from all the data, uh,
uh, a robot experiences, no matter how
good or bad it is.
And, uh, kind of extract some useful
signal from it.
Um, and this [clears throat] is, for
example,
uh, an area where where reinforcement
learning could be well suited to help.
But, basically the,
um, the goal is really to, uh, never try
to never throw away data.
Uh, because real-world data is like
very, uh, precious and expensive.
Um, this is
directly related to ano- another broader
open problem, uh, which is lifelong
learning, right? And so this means that,
um, in a nutshell, a robot should
improve over time,
um, by accumulating and learning, uh,
from all the experience and interaction,
uh, in the physical world, um,
similar to how intelligent, uh, beings
uh do.
However,
um the dominant uh paradigm nowadays is
that we train a model,
um we dep- uh we freeze its weights, we
deploy it,
and then ask it to generalize to novel
situations
um that uh its pre-training data might
not have uh prepared it for.
And so,
um besides the mixing
uh and learning from mixed quality uh
deployment data, um you know, you also
want to make sure um once you start um
fine-tuning on on this data, that you
don't have catastrophic forgetting, um
like forgetting about the model's
original capabilities, uh and so forth.
And so, this is uh a very exciting
problem um that will be a very, very
impactful.
Um
there [clears throat] is also a more
immediate version of of this. Um
what do you do if your policy fails
right now in the middle of deployment?
Right? So, instead of like uh re-
training your model,
>> [clears throat]
>> you want um to uh your model to have the
ability uh for rapid adaptation,
uh to recover on the fly. And um imagine
you unpack a robot uh at home for the
first time, and you um ask it to bring
you a Coke from the fridge, right? Um
and then maybe it tries, and it
struggles to uh grasp the ha- grasp the
handle of the fridge to open it. Um
maybe in that case, uh just giving it
some language feedback uh might be
enough. Right? Like you can maybe tell
the robot, like, "Oh, like, you just
need to grasp a bit more to the left."
Um that might that might suffice, right?
So, you put that kind of into the
context of the model, and then it can
like adapt, and and um
uh successfully finish the task. Uh but
maybe imagine it's more loss than that.
Uh maybe it doesn't know how to open the
fridge at all. So, the easiest way uh
might be for you to actually go there
and um do the demonstration yourself uh
of opening the fridge and then put that
into the context of your robot's model.
Also, this is kind of like the vision
for in context learning for robotics.
So, this means instead of
retraining your model every time it
encounters something new, you want a
model to have the ability
for rapid adaptation by doing some sort
of like few shot learning from whatever
signal is available.
Um
Now, if you remember a few slides ago, I
said in order to improve generalization
um
robots need the ability to expose
themselves to broader
and more diverse data that they can
learn from.
And now,
if we think about how mobile
manipulation looks like nowadays,
we see that it relies a lot on let's say
the traditional slam stack
to build like maps of the environment,
localize themselves,
plan the navigation, and so on. And
then, only once
the robot needs to interact with an
object, there is kind of like a hard
switch to then like move to a learn
policy like a VLA.
Um
>> [clears throat]
>> And so, there are several very
interesting open research questions here
where I think we will
hopefully converge to a more principled
approach that doesn't involve such a
hard switch. Um So, of course, first we
would like to have like a more unified
model that can do whole body control so
that it can handle both the navigation
and the manipulation part together. Um
And then second, there is a big question
mark on what is the best way to
represent the environment to allow for
long-range navigation in a in a big
building, for example.
Uh so, do we need like an explicit 3D
map of the environment? Maybe a
bird's-eye view projection. Uh,
maybe a topological map is enough or
scene graphs.
Or maybe just someone walking through
the um office like uh like a
walk-through video um with their iPhone
and then just put that kind of video
into the context uh of the model. Maybe
that's enough.
Um
>> [clears throat]
>> and how will such a model
uh like a such a unified model uh then
handle state estimation? Like uh will it
be like implicit? Uh will it be
explicit?
Um
>> [clears throat]
>> and uh if we put some sort of
environment uh representation into our
model's context, uh how do we handle uh
environment changes? Right? Cuz like the
environment is not static. It it like
continually like uh changes. Um we
probably also want to be able to uh
have some ability to adapt um to some
sort of to some sort of like local
navigation without a map. Um so these
are all very exciting open questions um
that I think are really uh fantastic to
to explore right now.
And
maybe the last one, if we have um such
mobile robots interacting with the
environment over prolonged periods of
time, then they should also of course be
able to do um this sort of lifelong uh
continual learning.
Um and if you think about this, we
stumble across uh
uh another very interesting question
which uh is about memory at scale.
Right? Because like a robot generates a
continuous streams of multimodal
experiences like video, depth, language,
touch, audio, bounding boxes, uh etc.
All of this is potentially useful, um
but the question is like what do you
store um and at what time scale, right?
Um this can range from
uh short horizon memories such as very
dense videos, um to longer horizon
memory, uh where you probably want to
try compressing experience into like
more semantic events uh that maybe like
helps you also remember uh what you
already have done and for like task
progress and so on.
Um but like then you have to kind of
uh think about uh when to write to
memory and what to forget, uh which is
also kind of a interesting question.
Um and then, you know, you can think
about this all the way to to years,
right? Like um how do you
uh
>> [clears throat]
>> uh how do you like store all of this?
How can you retrieve? Uh how do you can
you do like um
cross modal alignment and so forth?
Um
So, these are all interesting questions,
um and I can share some initial work we
have done towards addressing some of
these.
Um
>> [clears throat]
>> So,
VL maps uh fuses VLM embeddings into 3D
spatial maps, enabling uh zero-shot
spatial navigation uh to open vocabulary
targets without any training whatsoever.
Uh so, it's really out of the box.
Or uh Leela and um is um
kind of like learns how to do uh mapless
navigation
uh entirely from uh videos, like YouTube
videos.
Um and like
uh we showed that the uh
the more YouTube data we train on, the
better the performance gets uh for
uh open vocabulary uh mapless
navigation.
We also have some preliminary results on
how to use foundation models
uh to enable autonomous improvement uh
without human interventions,
uh for example, by um
>> [clears throat]
>> by proposing and and scoring um uh tasks
based on environment affordances.
And um
regarding adaptation, also um, a few,
for example, on the left, um, PAL is a
non-parametric approach um, that allows
generalist policies to adapt to new
long-horizon tasks with uh, as little as
five demonstrations, uh, while achieving
um, the same performance
um, that the full fine-tuning would uh,
achieve uh, for the same model with
around 100 demonstrations, if I remember
correctly.
>> [snorts]
>> And
>> [clears throat]
>> so, in order to achieve this kind of
embody embodied intelligence, um,
uh, I think a lot of the problems uh, I
just mentioned can be distilled into
this this pillars
uh, of embodied uh, reasoning, dexterous
mobile manipulation, lifelong learning,
and rapid adaptation.
Um, and so, these are the things that I
think that will actually um,
uh, that would that it that it uh, that
it would I think will actually
uh, will needed to be solved um,
um, to make robotics work, um, like not
just like for for like a demo video, but
like in general, um,
uh, so, maybe this is uh, my end game
for robotics.
All right. Um, so, I hope that after
this course, um, you all have a better
understanding um,
about like the tools that are available
um, in the modern modern robot learners'
researchers' um, toolkit.
And um, that if some of these problems
excite you,
uh, you can start advancing uh, the
frontier yourself.
Um,
but knowing what the open problems uh,
are is only like half the um, the
battle. Um, the other half is uh,
knowing how to do actually research in
in robot learning or in general research
in general. Um, so, um,
before finishing, I would like to share
a few things um, that I have learned uh,
about how to do research, uh, sometimes
the hard way, um, that I think um, might
be useful also for you.
So,
to start with
some uncomfortable facts of research.
First,
most of the research is incremental, and
that's not like a criticism.
That's usually how science works.
An analogy, for example, like today's
self-driving cars like rest on around 40
years of of like research and
accumulated work,
right? From like
the Alvin car in in 1986
to the DARPA challenge to end-to-end
modern learning.
Like nobody solved it in a single paper.
Right?
Second thing, most research ideas never
become papers. So, you might have like
10 ideas. Maybe you run like five
experiments and
get two interesting results.
And then maybe you publish one paper.
And that that would be like a good
ratio, I think.
But like the
like the the fact is that most of the
ideas you have like usually don't work,
right?
And that's like not like a failure, but
that's kind of the process that how it
goes.
And also, the third point is that most
of the papers
don't stand the test of time. So, the
field moves really fast and
you know, something that might feel like
a breakthrough today
might be
considered like a footnote in in 2
years, right?
Um,
and the fourth point I want to make is
that
So, in in in a world where where scale
is important,
simple ideas tend to have more impact
because they can be scaled more easily.
Um
so this means that if your idea requires
um 17 different moving parts to work, um
then maybe try to ask yourself if um
there is a simpler version
uh that gets you 80% uh of the way
there.
So how do you find a good research
problem? Uh what what is like a good
recipe for this? Um
I think it it's it's simple and I will
um
um briefly go over it.
Um
so uh first you need like an important
problem and then second you need a plan
for how to tackle it. Uh
you need like both, like the problem and
the plan. Um
just having one of one of the two
doesn't get you all the way there,
right? Um like an example, like you
could say
uh you know, let's cure cancer. Like
that's a really important problem,
right? Uh sounds very impactful. Um but
in this case if you don't know how, then
you know, maybe it's not the best idea
to start working on that, right? Uh
conversely, let's say you have a new
algorithm um that improves 1% on the
liberal benchmark, which is a very
narrow and saturated simulated robot
benchmark,
um that does not really like move the
needle on anything that matters.
Um so the sweet spot is
uh to try um to think of like a a
problem that is important and where you
have like some angle of attack or like
some plan on like how you want to like
address this.
Um
and then maybe the the last point here
is
uh it's also good to to think about um
you know, if your plan works exactly as
you uh as you have thought and you're
like successful, um how will this look
like? Um
what [clears throat] will it like
unlock? Uh how does it help the
community? Um
like will something be now possible that
wasn't um possible before. These are
good things to uh think about.
Um the next ingredient you need and
honestly
probably the most important one is
excitement
because a research takes a lot of time
and effort and you know experiments
don't work. There are deadlines.
Sometimes paper rejections.
Um and so you know it can be painful
sometimes um
and
what will probably make you more likely
to succeed is if you're also excited
about the problem
because if you kind of like find the
problem interesting and exciting
then the hard parts of getting there
like feel worth it if that makes sense.
Um
and if if if if you're not excited then
it just feels like work.
Um
All right.
The fourth there is a fourth ingredient
that I think is also quite crucial for
making
being successful in research
and you know hopefully you attack some
of the problems we just
mentioned before and this is trying to
be your own
reviewer number two.
So you know when like you submit like a
a paper to a conference you know this is
the reviewer that's like very critical
of your work.
Right? And
so
what I mean by this is that
um
before you go on and embark in a long
like you know multi-month like research
journey of a a particular problem you
should try to ask yourselves what is the
most likely reason that your idea might
fail.
Right? And now if you can answer that
honestly and you still believe that the
idea is worth
worth pursuing
um then then you're good then go ahead
and and proceed.
Um and
why I'm I'm saying you should try to do
this is because
this is um
a tool or a
basically a way you have to
protect your most valuable research
resource which is your time.
Right?
>> [clears throat]
>> In general, there are two different
styles of research
and it's worth knowing which one you're
which one you're approaching.
Um
there is the method-driven research
which starts usually with an idea or a
technique and then you kind of need to
find the right problem for it in order
to have an impact. Um today it could be
something like oh there you know a new
video diffusion model
just was released. Uh let me try to
apply it for robot manipulation uh
somehow like I don't really know like
what exactly what problem or how but
like
it's like a kind of like a cool new or
shiny model I want to like use it for
for something.
Uh problem-driven research starts the
other way around like you start with a
concrete problem.
Uh let's say uh for example how can I
make VLA generalized to a novel camera
viewpoint?
And then you go and find or invent you
know a method that solves it.
Um and so the problem is kind of your
anchor and your method is like whatever
like solves your problem best.
Both styles are can produce uh great
research. Um for a PhD I probably would
recommend problem-driven is safer uh
because if the method doesn't pan out
then you can try another one and you
will still be trying to solve an
impactful problem.
Um but if you never had like a impactful
like a real problem to begin with if
your method fails in the method-driven
research approach then you don't have
anything to
fall back on.
Um
Okay, but how do we actually do
research?
Um here are some loose tips. I always
recommend starting with
something that you know that absolutely
should absolutely work and then go make
make it incrementally harder. Right? So
maybe start with some over fitting
experiment before you try solving all
the problems at once.
Uh and also always make sure to
visualize both your inputs and outputs
to your models. It's really really
important.
Um
>> [clears throat]
>> because if you start at full complexity
and your experiment fails, then you have
no idea what the problem is.
So you need to know which parts work
incrementally in order to push the
boundary.
And
uh I also recommend always talking to
people about your idea, colleagues or
authors of papers you're building upon.
Uh this can really save you
weeks of effort and work.
Um
and once you have results, share them.
So share your findings with the
community, the people who care about
the same problems as you do. Might be
like your next collaborators, for
example.
Try open sourcing your your data, your
code as much as possible. This is the
most direct way
for your research to be useful for
others
other than yourself.
And also try to invest some time in
polishing your figures. Ideally,
someone should be able to look at your
figures and immediately understand
what's going on
without like reading the whole paper or
captions. If they have to make an effort
to understand your figures, then they
will move on and not bother like reading
like your paper or your blog or
whatever.
Um
and when sharing your research, be also
be mindful of your audience. Um so, in
doubt, don't assume that your audience
already knows all the same foundations
as you do.
Um
And of course,
one more thing on sharing, if nobody
knows about your research, then it
basically didn't happen. Uh so, a great
paper that nobody has read has like zero
impact. So, like try to disseminate your
findings, put your work on archive, post
about it on social media,
etc.
Um but, you know, remember like I think
this brings us kind of to the beginning
of the of today's talk.
Uh
you know, try to find the line between
like making people curious about your
work uh and
you know, not over hyping it by saying
you have solved robotics uh or like in
Brad Adcock's case, you know, where 2
years later after the tweet, we are
still waiting for his chat GPT moment in
robotics, right?
Um
I want to end today with a personal
story that I think maybe illustrates a
little bit some of the things that I
just tried to um
uh
>> [clears throat]
>> give you some suggestions on how to do
like research, how to tackle them.
Um so, early in my PhD,
I was kind of drowning in the classic
robotics pipeline. Uh I had
a thousand ROS nodes, disjoint models
for perception, planning, and control
that were accumulating errors across
all this all this super complex
pipeline.
Um
Not only that, like a week before a
major deadline, the robot broke. Uh it
wouldn't finish self-calibrating at
startup, so it wouldn't allow me to run
any of my code.
It was a bad time.
Um and as any good computer scientist,
you know, like any decent computer
scientist that you know, uh
that would ask you in a such a
situation, what do you do? Like you
try turning it off and on again, right?
So, that's what I did for actually a few
days until um
it somehow finished self-calibrating
like I think the night of the deadline
or something.
Uh and then I had to pull an all-nighter
to run all my experiments
for the deadline. And so, this traumatic
very traumatizing experience turned into
a bigger question for me. Uh can I ditch
all of this? Can I like forget about all
this Ross notes, all this super complex
pipeline with a thousand models
uh and just like accumulating all the
errors
um and do end-to-end learning?
Um
So, really uh like because of this
experience, I asked myself, what would
it take to have like a cool end of PhD
demo where instead of all this Ross
notes, I have like one model that can do
like multiple manipulation tasks like
end-to-end um
that can be like commanded and
instructed with language.
Um and so, I wrote actually a proposal
with some very loose ideas that got
accepted and funded me for a few years.
I then convinced my PhD advisor um
uh to buy me a Franka robot. I'm very
grateful um
for his help with this. And then I went
on and and spent like 1 year
setting this this robot up from from
zero with like custom heavy like a metal
table with holes
um I wrote writing like the VR teleop
code, mounting cameras, 3D 3D printing
the mounts for the wrist camera,
figuring out how to make the low-level
controller smooth and whatnot. All of
this
was like a lot a lot of work.
Uh so, I spent a year on this.
Um
and then once I had a working setup, I
started doing a bit more research. Once
I started doing research uh with it, I
quickly realized that iterating in the
real world would take me forever, but
that I I wanted to graduate at some
point. So, I started working on a
simulation environment that used
basically the same stack for teleop um
as you can see on the left video with
like the VR controller and so forth.
And after spending some time on making
the simulation nice, I realized that
actually there wasn't any simulation
like benchmark or dataset that allowed
training like these long horizon
language condition policies um uh that
required some degree of generalization.
So, I thought like well, maybe I can
like try to polish a bit my sim and
maybe like I'll make like a small paper
out of it or something in case it's
useful for others.
And so, this kind of like byproduct or
even like afterthought that I had become
then the Calvin benchmark um which to
this day is still one of my highest
cited papers and also won a best award.
Um
and building all this infra to set up
like visual motor control policies uh
was hard work.
Especially in a lab that primarily was
focused on doing slam.
Um but then this allowed me to iterate
very quickly um on the problem that I
actually wanted to solve.
Um it took me about 5 years with this
setup um to get to my cool end of PhD
demo that wasn't and running any ROS and
could do like over 25 like different
manipulation tasks
uh all grounded in language and
generalize, you know, to unseen
combinations of them and so forth.
Um so, I was very happy.
Um
Oh, okay, we are at time. So,
um so, this was my uh last lecture of
the course. Uh, because next week we
will have um, guest speakers only.
Um, so I [clears throat] wanted to take
a
uh, brief um, a brief moment to say
thank you. Um, uh, for all your patience
because um, this being a new course uh,
it has taken a lot of effort to put
together.
I really felt like um, we have been
flying a plane while
while uh, building it at the same time.
And uh, also a lot of thanks for like
the feedback you gave like uh, on the
midterm. That was really useful um, and
hopefully made the course better.
Um, this was the first time I had uh, I
have teach a full course um, and the
first one where I had to like also
design from scratch all the materials.
Uh, and so although juggling also two
full-time jobs uh, at the same time cuz
I'm not a professor. I work at industry.
I can say that teaching this course has
been an absolute privilege for me. Um,
and [clears throat] like seeing the
students excited about uh,
how their policies are training like uh,
scheming like to share data across
different teams
uh, or asking our guest speakers
insightful questions. I think that makes
me like really really happy. And um,
the goal of this course is really beyond
teaching you like the content and the
basics uh, really to inspire you that
robot learning um, is a cool field to
work on
uh, and I hope that we were able to
convey this.
Um, and with this uh, I'm also I'm
really looking forward to seeing um, all
your projects uh, with the real robots
on the demo day. I think that's that's
going to be a lot of fun. I can't wait
for it.
And uh, before we finish uh, and I pass
on to Lucas who hopefully somewhere
here. Um,
uh, I there is one more group I want to
thank um, I want to acknowledge um, the
teaching assistants.
Uh, because like this really would have
not been possible uh, without them. So
designing a new course from scratch
while working two full-time jobs is
hard, but the exercises, the project
supervision,
the robot setups, the TA session, that
was all of them. So I would ask the TAs
to stand up.
Please stand up and give let's give them
a big applause.
>> [applause]
[applause]
>> Awesome.
And with this we are done.
>> [applause]